some break in Hollywood news yeah
James Gunn director of Guardians of the
Galaxy the new suicide squad has just
become the head of DC Studios at
Warner's which is like in that in that
industry you never put a director the
director hasn't really been in charge so
he's going to be green lighting director
overseeing their slates well it could be
a whole new direction for all that Todd
Phillips will still handle his like
Joker and probably his dark movies his
way and then Matt Reeves has the Batman
World they don't know who's going to
control that but everything else
animation TV film under James that's
crazy because James Gunn got canceled
they tried to say he was a pedophile
because he made some kid [ __ ] jokes
and uh he was just too nice at making
movies and eventually they forgave him
he came back and now he's doing it so
does Kanye have a Road to Redemption
I think he was clearly joking is the
difference there were jokes and DC is
this lets me know how they know how much
DC is hating all their own movies yeah
that they're like just get the Marvel
guy I'm done yeah well look I think that
I think that James Gunn uh is a
absolutely talented [ __ ] he's
brilliant the question is will he be
talented in a managerial role that is a
different thing yeah you know he's
talented when he has his hands on it
he's that he's one of the greatest in
the world alive at making movies
I mean the guards of the Galaxy movies
are fantastic and you should not care
about the Guardians of the Galaxy I
didn't even know that was a comic book
and then the movie comes out I had no
emotional investment in Guardians of the
Galaxy watch the movie loved it yeah
Marvel is great about doing that with
movies I didn't even know were gonna
exist yeah yeah it's it's what it's uh
yeah it's weird even like even Thor
before the movies you heard of Thor but
none of us knew anything about it and
now he's one of the best superhero
characters in the entire Marvel Universe
yeah you know it's just taking on a
tough role though
the DC audience is super splintered like
there's like a core group that they like
that Snyder guy the Snyder yeah yeah and
like they just won't like anything DC
unless he has a part in it so it's like
I think I think the issue with DC is the
source material isn't as good they don't
have complex villains like their
villains are just all their let me just
get it out let me just get it out the
villains for Superman at are incredibly
simple I'm fire alien guy they don't
want anything like the beauty of Marvel
is the villain is relatable and they
made what the villain wants to be
reasonably relatable Thanos might be
right exactly every one of them might be
right even when you have X-Men it's uh
he's looking out for the mutants that
are getting oppressed yeah right so it's
like all of a sudden they make sense
every one of the DC in the Superman
world is like okay I got Superman now I
got water Superman now I got Woman
Superman now I got running fast Superman
they all got the same [ __ ] skill set
there's nothing unique or different like
what's the origin story get us into it
so they're almost like more video games
than there are these like complex
stories what they've done with Batman I
think is awesome but the source material
for Marvel is like on another level Lex
Luthor is just a bad guy yeah
there's no redeemable quality look at
his point of anybody it would be nice to
run the world we should let him do that
yeah yeah you're looking at Dan I was
like yo this [ __ ] might be the solution
to everything because
he's like I want to fix your problems
and leave I don't even want to be
worshiped even in the last one he's like
the only mistake I made is you all
remember everybody now I'm just gonna
get rid of half the population and you
won't know what happened I was like that
sounds kind of perfect yep yep I don't
know why are we stopping this I'll give
a little pushback because like in the
comics there is some depth with some of
the characters especially Lex Luthor
because they actually grow to like him
and start to hate Superman at a certain
point so it's like there is some depth
in the characters and I think it's more
so the writing and the creativity
because just because the comics have it
like black and white you can add that
you can add you can mine more I mean you
should wait for this wait for
Charlemagne to continue on this they did
it with the joker right like that Source
material wasn't really there but they
had great writers exactly so I think I
think the source material with the joker
there like the the one thing that the
Joker wants for Batman is to do the
thing that Batman refuses to do which is
kill and the Joker is willing to let him
himself be killed by like the pieces of
those stories that they added in he's
saying that might necessarily be in the
comic book that might be something that
the writer of the movie This agent of
chaos thing yeah I think that existed
but you're right yeah they made it
definitely more complex I will give them
that so if you add that same complexity
to all the other DC characters why
haven't they that's that's their issue
that's what they've they've just leaned
into the action and not so much the
story and that's where they've gone
wrong can I be honest I think the reason
why Thor has become way more like
comedic is because the bad guys that
he's going up against aren't that
interesting so they're like we got to
make this a comedy because the bad guys
are just I'm destroy worlds guy they did
a great job with the last one of giving
him purpose he wants to destroy Gods
because a God was the reason why he
suffered that's smart but God Destroyer
guy
yeah I'm evil incarnated Loki it was
just some Angry Kid yeah yeah I mean I
get it you're adopted you're not happy
about it the [ __ ] you want yeah right
but this is a cool shakeup and he's
partnering with his producing partner so
that he'll decide on things on an
executive level and then James Gunn will
go creative so the other thing Marvel
does is be funny
yeah these movies weren't funny I think
we for sure would have lost interest way
earlier at least I would have yeah I
know you would have Thor I remember
watching with you case Russell made us
go and we're both like why the [ __ ] are
we watching this and then it was funny
and we were like yo we're in taika
waititi yeah he's nice is it possible
that DC led the cancellation against
James Gunn in order to decrease his own
stock value so they could buy him up on
the left is it possible oh my God
where's that uh conspiracy like oh yeah
that [ __ ] seems a little convenient and
if I was them that's what I would do I'd
find the best people in Hollywood I
would lead to charge to make them look
crazy and then scoop them up when no one
else will touch them hey we'll give you
a shot that's what they're doing Kanye
yeah no Reebok is doing for Kanye right
now whoa that's my point